hey everyone i am nikunj jagawanshi i'll
be talking today about
interactive sound simulation and
the idea is to use physical simulation
of how
how sounds are produced and propagate
and are perceived
in virtual and game environments to make
them much more immersive
so a little bit about me to start off
i'm a principal researcher
in the microsoft research interactive
media group since 2009
where we do a lot of interdisciplinary
work mixing computer graphics vision
and audio modeling and before that i was
a phd at
unc chapel hill where i initiated the
direction of sound simulation research
there and my main interest through the
years has been
on efficient modeling of various
physical phenomena
especially on sound propagation which is
going to be the bulk of the talk today
the second half
so here's a quick rundown of today's
agenda
first i'll start very broadly i'll talk
about interactive simulation in general
and the challenges that are faced when
you try to do fast simulation in real
time
and those challenges are shared across
across
different kinds of simulation and then
i'll switch to
an overview of interactive sound
simulation
its various components and then give you
a flavor of the research in each of
those components
and then we'll go deeper into sound
propagation
and finally i'd conclude with some
outlook for the future and which
directions the research is heading
so let's start talking about interactive
experiences
so they can be defined as opposed to
linear media like
movies or video or tv which are fixed
experiences that are one way
just from the screen or the experience
to the viewer whereas interactive
experiences
such as games and virtual reality are
much more interactive and participatory
in fact in a multiplayer game you can
have multiple people interacting within
an
environment in unpredictable ways so in
linear
media because everything is fixed an
artist can
more easily fake various effects to
create realism and immersion
whereas in interactive media that can be
almost impossible
and it becomes really important to have
some kind of physical modeling
that is modeling how the world should
behave how different events
should make the environment react and
what sort of sensory perception people
get
and so the goal is to convince
perception
to create renderings that are believable
to people and physics is required to do
that because our perception is trained
every day
by looking at environments around us
so in terms of practice the biggest
platforms for doing interactive
simulation
are game engines like unity and unreal
and over the last many decades a lot of
work has been done
on various aspects of visual simulation
such as modeling shapes
like this background picture is a
screenshot from a real-time demo that
recently came out for unreal engine 5.
and you can see it's very realistic you
have all these details on these shapes
and there's a lot of collision modeling
say rocks are falling on these walls
how they collide with the environment
and light simulation how it bounces
around the seat and casts shadows
and creates very convincing lighting
and this doing this in real time is a
huge challenge
the three top technical issues the first
one is
that these scenes are very complex in
general so
any practical technique needs to handle
very general scenes
and it needs to handle them and produce
believable
and immersive renderings and robustness
is a very important concern that
you shouldn't have corner cases where
suddenly it produces something different
and wrong because a perception latches
on to anything out of the ordinary
so that is a very high bar to cross and
you have to do both of these things
and their intention with efficiency you
have to do it fast
at 30 to 60 frames a second so there's a
lot of innovation that has happened
in designing efficient algorithms that
do clever approximations with knowledge
of
the physical phenomena themselves as
well as lock lockstep
growth in hardware in graphics
processors to do this processing
but these are all the technical sides of
making this feasible
a system can meet all these requirements
and still fail in the real world because
there's also a set of practical
requirements to make such systems
feasible
a big a big point here is automation the
technique shouldn't require too much
manual work or
tagging of the environment to make it
work because then that just replaces one
kind of work with another
bringing to the right there should be
nice integration
in existing tools so there's a gradual
path to adoption
instead of requiring you to throw away
all the tools you had start with new
ones and
retrain people to use those new tools
and these things come together in the
hands of the
designer who needs to be able to wield
some
kind of control on the physical
simulation it can't simply be like
this is what the simulation gave us we
go with that because at the end of the
day
these are designed experiences so all
these six
considerations go into any kind of
interactive simulation
and they apply just as well to sound
simulation which is what i'm going to
talk about today
so here's the big picture of sound
simulation and how to do it
interactively
so usually it is modeled as a feed
forward pipeline
it has three components there's sound
synthesis which is how sounds are
created say you clap in a room
then from there sounds propagate or move
in an environment to get to the listener
that is sound propagation and once they
arrive around the listener
they need to be displayed to the user
through either headphones or speakers
which is spatialization
the path of sound simulation has been
has seen more ups and downs compared to
visual simulation there was a lot of
fast technology development in the 90s
but
since around 2005 the emphasis has been
more
on making new design tools interactive
audio design tools
different from say movies and examples
of such
tools are audio kinetic wise and fmod
which are used a lot in games these days
and if you want to know more about this
history you should definitely check out
this talk i've referred here but since
2015 the field has seen a resurgence
because
in large part from virtual and mixed
reality and part of the reason is that
spatialization technology has matured so
there's technology like dolby atmos and
windows sonic
that provide spatialization to all users
for example in windows 10 and spatial
sound you can find these settings to
turn them on
what that does is this higher quality
display through spatialization sets the
stage for better simulation
because now you can the better
simulation
seems so much nicer to the user because
they come across better
and around the same time many
propagation technologies have also
shipped which i'll talk about
another positive development is next
generation consoles
have hardware acceleration for audio so
we're starting to see that virtual cycle
just like graphics of better algorithms
and better immersion
and better hardware support
so before i go further let me give you
an example of what i mean by an
interactive sound simulation
this particular simulation is with
project acoustics in unreal engine i'll
i'll talk about those do use headphones
to listen to this demo and all the demos
i'm going to show today
so what i'm showing you here is there's
only one sound source in a cave it's
just a drip sound
and you're just walking around this
environment and what i want you to
listen for
is just how much immersion is added
by modeling how the sound echoes through
the space how it's obstructed by various
surfaces
and especially in combination and
visuals how well it conveys this sense
of presence in an environment to you
my
so as you heard you get a very immersive
sense
of the sound as you go close as you go
far away it gets more reverberant and so
on
and that's the goal of interactive sound
simulation
is to produce these immersive renderings
without requiring any
manual work so for example in this case
this was all done through simulation
on the geometry you saw with the
materials it had
without any hand tuning on top of it
so here's the structure of the rest of
the talk i told you about these three
components so first i'll talk about
sound synthesis give you some flavor of
the research there i'll talk very
briefly about spatialization
and then i'll go to propagation and talk
more in detail about about that
so let's talk about sound synthesis or
it's as it's called in audio circles
physical modeling synthesis and the idea
is to
follow the physics of how sounds are
produced which is for example when you
strike a bell
its surface starts to vibrate and then
those vibrations push and pull the air
around the bell
and as that happens air compresses and
ratifies
and these compressions and rarefactions
pressure fluctuations in the air
that is sound that's perceived by our
ears as sound
so to model this physics there are many
efficient algorithms
one of them is modal synthesis for
quasi-rigid objects
and here's a quick intuition of what it
is so if suppose you have a
one-dimensional string like a guitar
string and you want to model its
vibrations what you can do is break down
its vibration into these elementary
modes of vibration
over space and then any vibration of the
string can be expressed as a sum of
these vibrations so i'm going to play
this
so each of these elementary modes is
producing a corresponding sound to the
right which is a damped sinusoid
and if you sum those damn sinusoids you
get the overall sound that the string
produced
so you can see initially in the sound
there's a lot of transient structure
that's like the click sound when you
do the strike after that it's followed
by this long harmonic oscillation that's
the ringing of the bell afterwards
so this was in one dimension but it does
generalize to three dimensions so these
are the mode shapes of a bowl for
example
and here's a quick demo from some work i
did many years ago
just to show you what modal synthesis
can do so you have three materials
word metal and plastic and various
objects and this is just a sandbox in
which you're just doing free-form
interaction with these objects and
they're responding to collisions
like they would using a physics engine
in a game
[Music]
so
so as you can see you get this very
nuanced
synchronized effects between visuals and
audio like
how the sound responds to the rolling
speed of an object
or objects of various materials
colliding with each other
directly through simulation and again
this is just directly from the geometry
of the objects and the material
parameters for each
but industrial uptake for such
physically based methods has been
limited
the it's very common still to use
pre-made sounds such as in a digital
audio workstation much like movies
and then based on game events that
happen like collisions you trigger a
pre-baked sound
so you don't get as much granularity in
the simulation
as a result and this is my opinionated
view
of why the situation is like that
partly it's again going back to this
rubric of what makes a technique
practical
so in terms of general scenes and
believability
and in terms of automation the
techniques can be pretty good especially
modal synthesis
but when it comes to efficiency it
really ma depends on what you're talking
about for rigid body sounds
modal synthesis is close enough although
perhaps it needs even more optimizations
to make it practical
but for example on the other extreme
water sounds are really really difficult
the physics is really much more
complicated
and then there's the question of tools
integration making it so that
it's such physical synthesis is easy to
use
within existing game engines
like taking the data from the collision
physics and having it routed to the
physical simulation system
that can be difficult and you can also
face limitations there
of just that for example that the
physics runs at
30 frames a second and not at much
higher rates that audio can
perhaps need and finally because of this
like we haven't dug very deep
into what sort of design controls you
might need if somebody if an artist says
uh i want control on these physical
sounds in such and such way
we haven't established a vocabulary for
doing that
i should mention that there's a good
work right now on procedural audio which
is the broader
goal of having physically inspired
methods
that just produce synchronized audio
with visuals
in with some parametric control and some
work is happening there
and perhaps and these methods are much
more practical today so perhaps
a good way to look at it is starting
with these methods and making them more
and more physically
accurate or more and more physically
based
and perhaps that's the way to go
so for further reading i refer you to
the excellent book from pericook that's
up top
that's a good overview of real-time
synthesis
the two papers after that are seminal
papers in the area of using rigid
efficient rigid body sound synthesis and
the paper after that is some of my work
which i showed you the demo of
and this system is less accurate but
it's it can be much easier to implement
as well
and for the latest research in the area
i'd refer you to
work from dr doug james and his students
who've done a synthesis for
all sorts of interesting phenomena like
liquids and cloth and thin shells and so
on
all right so that was synthesis let's
now
move to sound spatialization so somebody
did a simulation using synthesis
propagation
and we know the sound field around the
listener it's the job of a spatializer
to take that field and convert it
to signals that should be played over
headphones or over speakers
to recreate the impression
so usually this a spatializer will have
all kinds of signal processing
algorithms
to do this transformation and it's more
heavy on signal processing rather than
physical simulation itself
to give you a flavor of the current
research and keep in mind this is a much
vaster area than one slide would
convey so it's i've just picked a few
things here
so it's not a complete description but
there are two related problems that
people are looking at
one is the problem of sound field
representation
which is that what do you represent this
input sound field in the form of
and a classic way to do that is channel
based so for example in a 5.1 surround
system
you have five directions and you just
produce five signals
saying what came from front front left
and so on
this can be less accurate because for
intermediate directions you interpolate
or pan into the on to these directions
the other extreme is object-based where
you break down the whole
sound field into elementary events so
for example if you have a forest scene
each bird is a sound source each leaf's
rustling is a sound source
so obviously this is very high fidelity
but it can also get very expensive and
then there's modal
techniques which has connections to
modal synthesis that i described to you
where you take the spherical sound field
and represent it as a sum or linear
combination
of many elementary basis functions
on the sphere for example spherical
harmonics
so all these methods have different
tradeoffs in terms of how compact the
representation is how much the rendering
cost is
what the rendered quality is and finally
design controls because
channel base for example is very
intuitive to think about whereas model
can be less intuitive to think about
so there's a lot of research going on in
industry and academia to figure out what
is a good solution going forward for
immersive audio
and then there are spatialization
algorithms that take these sound fields
as input and i'm going to give you a
brief sense of
uh hrtf's head related transfer
functions which are used for banana
rendering over headphones which is
because of virtual reality there is a
lot of research going on in this area
right now
and the idea of hrtfs is you can
tabulate
how the head and shoulders of a person
modify
sound coming from a specific direction
as it scatters from the head and the
ears
and that's the hrtf and then
at runtime based on wherever resources
you figure out the filter for the left
and right ear
and do a convolution of the sound source
sources signal with the corresponding
filters and that creates the two signals
you should send in because it recreates
what would happen in reality and this
can create very impressive effects which
where sound sources are externalized and
have a very crisp direction
but here are some questions that people
are looking at
so firstly hrtfs depend on the person's
head size their pinner shape and all
these considerations so
the question is how much and how to
personalize these hrtfs in a practical
way
and how much do you need that for
various applications say
virtual reality as opposed to mixed
reality
where you can actually hear real sounds
and perhaps the bar for realism
is much higher to convince somebody that
a virtual sound is also located in the
same space
there's other related questions like
coloration that
hrtfs always have to introduce some sort
of equalization
and making that perceptually transparent
can be tricky
in practice there's the question of
localization accuracy
how high fidelity does the hrtf need to
be
and all these questions basically can be
framed into one big question what makes
an hrtf good enough what is the accuracy
bound you need
and how does that vary depending on the
application
and again this this is these are a few
questions there's a lot of
hard questions in this area and a lot of
work is going on in that field right now
and then these problems are
interconnected how do you represent the
field and what spatialization algorithms
you need
the the answer to all of this is perhaps
one answer or a set of
consistent answers so for further
reading i'd refer you to
these two books up top which are about
the psychophysics of hearing and
then more practical aspects of it
and this is not an exhaustive list by
the way these are just some interesting
readings that i picked out
the third one is ville pulkey's classic
paper on vbap for speaker panning
the fourth in the list is research
that's going on
in microsoft in the audio and acoustics
group
uh on hitf modeling and binaural
rendering and a lot of this technology
has shipped in
microsoft hololens for producing spatial
audio
renderings so there's a link that to
that work
but really there's a lot going on and
the best way to
know about it is to is conference
proceedings or to attend conferences
like aes conventions avar
and i casp any talk about 3d audio or
spatial audio is talking about hrtfs
in some sense and aes avar is coming up
very soon so i encourage you to attend
that
all right so i talked about synthesis
and spatialization
let's now start digging into sound
propagation
which is how does sound move once it's
produced from a sound source how does it
move through a space to get to the
listener
there's been a lot of work on this in
the area of room acoustics
and the picture on the right is taking
taken from the cover art of the book by
cut roof
i highly recommend reading this book
cover to cover if you're interested in
the area
and the typical problem here is you have
a concert hall
and you have a sound source there on the
stage and there's a listener
sitting on a seat and you want to
predict you want to do a predictive
simulation
of how what the listeners perception
would be of of that space
to do that it's very common to use um
high frequency approximations to actual
to the actual wave equation which is
which is ray tracing and that makes some
modeling some diffraction wave effects
like diffraction difficult
but it's a very efficient method so what
you do is these you trace these ray
paths from source to listener
and as they bounce around the scene the
model reverberation and interesting cues
like that
so ray tracing is a good fit for room
acoustics because the line of sight is
clear
usually between the source and listener
you have a single enclosure
and that means that diffraction effects
are wave effects can boost accuracy so
they're good to have
but they don't entirely forestall
using ray methods you can actually get
good approximations using it
so for further reading uh dark shoulders
thesis is a
is a good resource to learn about ray
tracing methods for real-time
oralization
and there's also below that is an
overview or survey paper on geometric
techniques
so from room acoustics we know how to
characterize propagation
with the concept of an impulse response
and the idea
is that if you have a source and
listener in a room
you play an impulsive sound like a clap
or a balloon pop
from the source and you record what the
listener gets that's the impulse
response
and once you know the impulse response
then later on
whichever signal the source emits you
can do a convolution of the impulse
response with it
to recreate how it would sound when it's
filtered through the room
so that's the key trick that lets you
separate whatever sound you're going to
play on later
with uh the transfer or the effect of
the room on the sound of the space on
the sound
and there's a lot of knowledge we
already have on the structure of a
typical impulse response
so say you have the situation as shown
on the right so initially you will have
a direct path or initial sound
propagating from the source to the
listener that's the
that's the initial spike here then
you'll have a few bounces from geometry
in the room that's the early reflections
and these are clear and they convey
spatial presence like proximity to
surfaces
and then over time you have much more
complex paths and it gets very noisy and
that's late reverberation
so i'm telling you this because it sets
some vocabulary that i'll be going back
to
as we go ahead
finally you can assign directions to
each of these arrivals at the listener
and that gives you what's called the
directional impulse response and the
directional impulse response is
sufficient information
to give you the whole sound feel around
the listener that the sound was heard
from here a reflection came from the
left and so on
so i told you about room acoustics and
the use of ray tracing methods
in interactive audio you have a
different set of problems
because the line of sight is obstructed
many many times it's a very common
scenario
and this can be summarized with what's
called the lamppost problem
and the idea is suppose you used a
simple system to model
obstruction which is you traced array
from the source to listener and you said
if there's anything in the way i'm going
to reduce the loudness of the sound by
some amount
now the issue is if you have thin
geometry like a lamp post
small motions of the listener can have
the line of sight clear or obstructed
and create these loudness fluctuations
which you don't hear in real life
and it's it's immersion breaking
a complementary problem is the pinhole
problem which is
if you have say non-water tight meshes
so there's little apertures or gaps
between triangles
then suddenly you can hear a sound with
full loudness as it goes
as you establish line of sight which is
also unintuitive
in reality what you expect is
as the size of the obstruction or the
aperture changes smoothly
the loudness of the sound adjusts
smoothly as well which is closer to
physics
and that's because of diffraction so it
becomes quite indispensable
in interactive applications for
producing natural results that are
robust
and don't change
too harshly over space they stay smooth
so i've been talking about diffraction
let me show you what it looks like
so on the right you see a wave
simulation which is
using a grid solver on to model a volume
of air and all the pressure fluctuations
within it
i'm showing compressions with red and
rarefactions with green
so as the source emits the sound the
wavefront wraps around this obstruction
to get to the listener
that's diffraction that sound waves tend
to bend around
obstacles so we need to model this
to solve the lamppost problem and the
pinhole problem
but there are many more acoustic effects
that are of interest in interactive
audio
that also don't have line of sight one
of them is portaling
which is the everyday experience that
sounds redirect around doors and
you tend to hear coming from doors
rather than wherever the source is in
line of sight
and that's again because sounds bend
around and diffract around these door
edges
and if you have multiple sources in a
room like on the left you expect the
sounds to funnel through a doorway and
arrive at you
and this helps a lot in helping the
listener localize themselves and situate
themselves in a space
then there's occlusion which is just the
total power of the sound
including initial sound and reflections
then this reverberance or wet ratio
which is that
a listener behind a partition in this
case will get a
weaker initial sound compared to a
listener right in front of a source
whereas the reverberation in both cases
is similar so when you're behind the
partition
the sound is more echoey it's it's more
reverberant and that conveys the
impression that you're in a different
space from the sound source
and this is this is hard to fake by hand
it's it's common to tune this using just
distance in games but clearly that's not
enough in complex scenes
finally there's decay time which is that
just that a bigger room
with the same material reverberates for
longer than a small room
so these are some of the effects that
are of interest it's this isn't this was
not an
exhaustive list of effects but this
gives you some sense of the sort of
scenarios facing interactive audio
now these were simple scenes for
illustration but in reality
scenes can be much more complex so this
this is a
a more representative scene there's a
cathedral on the left i've taken the
roof off we're looking at a top down
and if you think about what the initial
sound looks like in this scenario it
emits from the source
and say the listener is inside so it
emits from the source it has to defract
many many times around various edges
wrap around it to flow to the listener
and there are other complex paths
also involved in the initial sound
reflections and reverberation look much
more complex you have many many
complicated paths that connect the
source to listener so modeling all this
in real time can get really compute
intensive
and that's why games typically use
techniques like reverb volumes where
a designer would say i'll just draw this
box around the cathedral
and whenever the listener enters this
box
i'm going to turn on such and such
filter cathedral
impulse response and then i'm going to
just use that filter on the sound to
convey that you're inside a cathedral
the difficulty with that is you end up
having to draw
many many volumes this is a lot of
tedious work and it's error prone it's
bug prone
it's just a lot of manual work that
that requires a lot of time investment
so to solve these issues a lot of
interactive sound propagation
systems have been proposed to automate
this process
the systems on the left use geometric
approximations ray tracing techniques
that i talked about
the steam audio and google resonance
don't model diffraction but they focus
on reverberation modeling and
spatialization
wise reflect tries to model
[Music]
diffraction such as portaling and
obstruction effects but
it requires a simplified acoustic mesh
so you have to take your scene and make
a simplified version that's watertight
because it has the pinhole problem
um and then you have to do some mock-up
for the doors
and then if the scene gets very complex
the cpu cost starts going up so there's
a trade-off there to balance
on the other hand is triton which i'm
going to talk about today which uses the
wave simulation like the simulations i
just showed you
so it does full physical modeling it
includes all the diffraction effects
but the cost for that is precomputation
which does bring its limitations
which i'll get into
so to give you some background project
triton is something i've been leading in
microsoft research since
2010 in collaboration with john snyder
and over the years many different
product partners
and it's it's the first physics system
that was used in a game
to provide physical propagation effects
like obstruction and dynamic reverb
which was gears of war in 2016 and
there's a gdc talk
below that talks about that particular
integration that might be of interest
so let me show you some demos of the
system in gears of war
so in this particular scene there's only
one sound source the helicopter
and i'm going to give you a baseline
first with no acoustics so it's just
distance attenuation
and then i'm going to switch triton on
and show you what it sounds like
especially how the obstruction sounds
like in various spaces
so again this was driven directly from
the geometry and the materials of the
scene
and note how the obstruction effects are
giving you a sense of
where the helicopter is and without even
looking you can sense
whether you're in immediate danger from
it versus not
so such effects are really important in
games
the second demo shows uh
more how the reverberation varies in a
small room versus a big room versus
outdoors
and again first i'll start with off to
set a baseline and then turn it on
i'd say it's about time we got the hell
out of here hey are we not going to talk
about what happened back there
with the nests i mean what the hell was
that it looked like they were
transforming
wait you mean like evolving shouldn't
that take a lot of time
i'd say it's about time we got the hell
out of here hey are we not gonna talk
about what happened back there
with the nest i mean what the hell was
that it looked like they were
transforming
wait you mean like evolving shouldn't
that take a lot of time
well some insect juveniles can become
drones in days
hours even so juvies and drums
jews and drones i have a feeling we're
gonna find out
so audio plays almost a subconscious
role
in boosting the sense of space as
they're having a conversation to various
spaces without looking too much around
they have a sense of where they are and
that's the importance of audio in these
experiences
this demo shows occlusion on rain sounds
and how they vary naturally throughout a
space
so you get these smooth nice variations
throughout the space and this would be
very hard to do by hand
because you'd have to paint a loudness
map through the scene saying how loud
the rain should be everywhere which is
quite infeasible in practice
so since gears of war 4 triton has
shipped in many more games and in
virtual reality
so it does provide some confidence that
it's a practical system today for any
experience
it has shipped in virtual reality
experiences like windows
mixed reality and all space vr
sea of thieves used it to provide
obstruction effects for example if
you're below deck in a ship
and there's somebody above deck they're
very close to you in
in the sense of distance but their sound
should be very muffled
and triton is able to model such effects
gears 5 in 2019 showed that you can how
you can combine
i was telling you about propagation and
spatialization so gears 5 is a good
showcase combining how you can use good
sound simulation
and combine that with latest
spatialization technologies like dolby
atmos and windows sonic to produce a
much more immersive experience
and finally borderlands 3 is is
interesting
in being the first product that's not
from microsoft to use this technology
talking about external usage uh triton
is available externally in the form of
project acoustics
and which is you can download from this
link
and it takes triton it takes our hrtf
technology that's used in
windows sonic and hololens and it
makes them easy to use as plug-ins for
unity and unreal
so they can be they can be very easy to
use for for example for research
purposes or commercially
there's a gdc talk here showing the
workflow and the use cases for the
technology
and it's pretty cross-platform across
consoles pc we have an android demo
it works in virtual reality and i'll be
showing you a demo on the hololens later
on
so let me give you a technical flavor of
the main ideas behind triton and why
it's practical
the first idea is i told you that we
want to model diffraction
so the way to model that is to do a wave
simulation
which is a grid solution of the volume
of
air and that's very expensive that's way
way more expensive than ray tracing
so the first idea is do it beforehand
pre-compute this wave simulation
on a static scene and you get a
simulation in a complex scene the
simulation would look something like
this so
you take a potential listener location
you send out a probe signal which is a
pulse
those wavefronts propagate out through
the scene
and then you put microphones throughout
so at point a you get starting to
getting get some signal then the
waves wrap around over the walls and get
to point b
and essentially you're you're collecting
these acoustic impulse responses
that i told you about that characterize
what happened to the sound on its way
from the source to listener
and in practice for every such
simulation we collect
millions of impulse responses and then
we repeat this procedure for
a lot of possible samplings of listener
locations
so that shifts the problem from
computation to memory
because we know the answer in terms of
the impulse response so at runtime
it's just a table lookup to find what
the impulse response should be
but the difficulty is this is terabytes
of data
so we have a compression problem so the
second idea comes
in that instead of keeping the simplest
responses
we know the sort of effects we're after
like obstruction occlusion so we figure
out which parameters
perceptually capture those effects and
we just extract those out
so the example here is you you compute
the onset delay the initial delay of the
sound
loudness and direction for the initial
sound for the reflections
you have the initial delay for the first
reflection
and then some overall distribution of
the energy of those reflections so
to capture some spatial or directional
aspects of them
and then for reverberation you have a
decay time so in all
the details here don't matter so much
the main idea is you've gone from this
long signal in time
to 12 numbers that are perceptually
meaningful
and that's a lot of compression right
there
that brings us to the third idea now you
can take
how these parameters vary over space so
for example i've shown initial direction
and loudness here
you can you can see how they vary over
space and map
out what are called parameter fields and
when you map them out
you see for you see that they're pretty
smooth so in this case you can see the
color which is loudness is varying very
smoothly
similarly the direction is pretty
constant over most of space
so you can do compression on this for
example you can use an image compressor
on such smooth images and reduce the
data so
all in all that reduces the ram from
roughly 100 terabytes to 100
megabytes which is a factor of a million
compression and that makes it practical
to load up this
data at runtime in a game
and the cpu is small because we
pre-compute it so it's just
table lookups and interpolations at
runtime so it's just 100 microseconds to
take a source and figure out
what its acoustic parameters should be
given its location and the listeners
location
so here's some more demos this one is
showing more of the obstruction
portaling and the spatial audio effects
that i was talking about
and this is a long demo it's about two
minutes and you should read the captions
up top
and they will describe to you what you
should be hearing
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
so these effects that you heard
especially towards the end
where the sounds are opening up the
soundscape opens up when you walk into a
space and falls back down into doors as
you walk out
they're pretty difficult to do without
modeling physically and modeling
diffraction
in real time
so here's some more recent work this is
this is pretty exciting
this is a showing for the first time i
believe
diffraction and obstruction effects in
mixed reality
and i highly recommend going to the
stock at the link below
which talks about the system in more
detail
but essentially we're using depth scan
geometry of the space to drive acoustics
so it's showing just one sound source
and it's showing how it's obstructed and
gets portaled around doors
even in a real space so what you're
seeing is a live capture through a
hololens 2
and again it shows first acoustics
disabled then enabled
[Music]
so these are initial results for sure
but they're very promising
so if you have lots of people in this
room
you could expect to reproduce the effect
of when you're outside there's chatter
in a room heard through a door
and you walk in and the soundscape
envelops you
in mixed reality so some of the
participants could be real some could be
virtual
for example
so let me go back to my rubric that i
showed initially and talk about how
triton fits within that
how it represents one possible practical
solution for interactive propagation
so by doing wave simulation we can model
general scenes because it's the first
principle solution
and we get believability and robustness
because we're modeling diffraction
and it's also highly automatic because
we just
take the scene geometry and voxelize it
for a grid solver
so there's no need for a spec special
simplified geometry for running the
acoustic simulation
it's also very efficient because we
pre-compute everything and compress it
down
and this i didn't get into much but
because we're using these perceptual
parameters
audio engines are pretty good at
parametric rendering
so there's a way to map these parameters
onto standard audio engines to do the
rendering
so it does not require complete changes
to audio engines to enable these
which is played a big part in why we
were able to ship it in gears of war to
begin with
and finally there's design control and
because these parameters are meaningful
they're things like
how much loudness do you hear a designer
can say
change that change whatever physics
computed so do a little more obstruction
than what physics wanted or do a little
less obstruction than what it wanted
or the designer could say i want the
space to be a bit more reverberant than
what its materials and volume would
suggest
for artistic effect so they can just say
a multiplier for example
make it 1.5 times whatever physics had
the important thing
is the designer is not having to say the
acoustics should be such and such
they can simply say i like it most of
the time but in these places
modified whatever the acoustics is
physically
in such and such way which is much less
manual labor and much more time for the
artistic work
that they want to do the issue is that
we can't handle dynamic scenes
because it's precomputed so we have to
pick the geometry we have to know it
beforehand
to some extent this problem is solvable
although not completely
so if you know that the dynamic geometry
is going to be
in places you already know about such
for example such as doors
then one can do something about it so
this is a demo from very recent work i
did
on modeling doors within triton
and what you have here are two sound
sources there's a storm
outside there's water dripping inside
and look how the
door modifies and affects the two sounds
[Music]
so what the system is doing is using
pre-computed data
and combining it with whatever the state
of closure of the door is
in real time so the door could be in any
state and the sound would adjust to it
and this shows that to some extent
including dynamic effects is possible
but fully dynamic geometry is difficult
so
that hopefully gave you some technical
flavor of triton
and to learn more about it i refer you
to the papers i won't go through these
details but if there's one paper you
read
it's i would suggest starting with the
second one which introduces the main
idea
behind parametric compression
to recap triton um
is a practical solution for doing sound
propagation including all physical
aspects like diffraction
and it's been used in practice so it
shows that for interactive sound
propagation
you can have practical solutions that
can ship in games today
but it's definitely not the final answer
because it's limited to mostly static
scenes
and my view of it is more like light
baking in games which is a standard
technology and it's
it's motivated from similar
considerations that doing
the whole light transport simulation in
real time can be very difficult
so you do it beforehand and then you
layer some dynamic stuff on top of it
but like lighting sound
for sound the next frontier would be
fully dynamic scenes that's where
lighting is going as well
to model all these phenomena in real
time
except for sound we'll also have to
worry about diffraction
and that would that's a much harder
problem but that's also a much more
interesting problem as well
and that would require innovation in
fast wave solvers to model diffraction
hybridizing wave based methods with ray
tracing methods to use both of their
strengths
and then worry about scalability to much
larger scenes because game scenes are
becoming bigger and bigger
so that's my talk let me give you
some sense for the future
i today i talked about sound simulation
and its three main components
synthesis propagation and spatialization
and spent a lot of time giving you some
sense of
propagation and triton
the future for sound simulation is very
promising
because of all these different
applications that are lining up
in the near future there's a lot of
interest
in such technology for example in
virtual reality you have much more
close and nuanced interactions with
individual objects
so synthesis becomes quite important
to do so as to not break the immersion
in mixed reality the north star is to
have convincing interactions have
virtual holograms of people that share
the space with you
and modeling their acoustic effects
in a convincing way can move the state
of the art that much forward and create
some really compelling experiences
games continue their march forward on
immersion and realism
and it's great that audio is catching up
now and more and more immersive audio
simulation will be needed
to to have audio visual immersion and
games
then there's applications in
accessibility for vision impaired users
where audio becomes the primary sensory
cue
and there's been some work in the
ability team in microsoft research
who used triton in their cane troller
project to train
blind users to use a virtual cane
in more complex environments so for
example in a two-room environment with a
wall in between
the propagation and portaling cues can
help inform a person which way to walk
and not run into walls
and finally there's building and urban
acoustics where the application would be
immersive walkthroughs
and noise control applications and
especially in architecture right now the
digital transformation going on it's
become more and more common
to have a whole digital model of the
building and to do walkthroughs within
game
engines so sound simulation can provide
the acoustic component
important acoustic component to those
experiences
so that was my talk thanks for attending
and please stick around for the live q a
thank you
hey everyone thanks for attending my
talk today it's nikunj here
and i hope you enjoyed it uh my
discussion of interactive sound
simulation so
over the next 15 minutes or so i'll be
answering some of your the top questions
here and there's
there's been a lot of questions so i'm
just sorting them in real time here
uh so let's let's just get going so the
first thing i'll say
is some of you are talking about just
the videos and the
sound is coming out as mono uh or you
have some delays in the audio and video
so i'll say in the resource list to your
right
uh the presentation slide deck is
available right on top
so you can download that and see it and
view it
at your leisure with a good headphone
setup whenever you want
okay so let's get to the technical
questions
one of the questions is what is lost in
this com perceptual compression process
and if you do an av listening test do
you hear
a difference and the answer is yes you
definitely hear a difference there are
many things left to do
in our compressor we basically started
with saying
what will fit within the resource
constraints of a game and sound
reasonable
and add realism as we go from there
that's been the process here
so some of the things we know are
missing a big one that's missing is
discrete reflections when you're
outdoors you get slap back echoes
and we have one reflection delay but
really uh
you need a few reflections uh to get an
immersive sense
of a space so that's something that
we're working on
and similarly there are other things
related to that like
outdoors doesn't sound as good because a
lot of our work has been based on room
acoustic theory so
things tend to sound like rooms with our
system but we do
have this outdoorness factor that we use
to make outdoors sound better
but basically there's a lot to dig here
so it's really there's a lot of fun
research to do in this area
of parametric compression for
interactive audio
all right next question uh
so somebody tested out the technique and
they're saying it's too
it sounds too echoey in some cases and
the related question is
do we handle frequency dependent
boundaries no we don't and that could be
a reason it can be a bit echoey
sometimes
and this is something we're actively
working on right now
because real acoustic materials have
reflectivity that depends heavily
on frequency so we're we're actively in
the process of adding that
but it will it will take a while we
don't have a
uh eta on that currently but that's
something we're looking into and we know
that it's an issue
for sure one thing i'd say is if it's
too echoey in some cases
you can definitely in our unreal
immunity plugins
you can definitely edit the materials
reflectivity so we just have a flat
frequency independent reflectivity and
you can easily change that
so if if things are too echoey that's
one way to tone them down to bring down
those
to increase those absorptivity to reduce
the reflectivity whatever the case may
be
all right so after that let's see
so one question was related to uh
pre-computation
like why is azure required and
where does the precomputation happen how
long does it take so the idea is that
this wave simulation is very expensive
so we need a compute cluster for this
thing to do this pre-computation
in a reasonable amount of wall clock
time and the good thing is
each of these simulations that i've been
showing you can be done independently
so if you go really wide and allocate a
lot of machines
then the simulations can finish in even
half an hour
and that's why that's one of the reasons
we when we ship these plugins we made
azure the
the default option is that lets you
azure batch lets you do that very easily
and gives you reasonable turnaround
times but i will add that the unity
plug-in
does have the option of doing these
simulations locally
but they do take much longer because
it's only a single machine
that's doing it another question is is
the source code for project acoustics
available
so we are making it available through
the
gdk program so for game developers
if you already have a gdk agreement in
place to use it for
xbox to ship your games then we made it
very easy
with a one page agreement for you to get
the source code access
uh for free for project acoustics
and a related question is a striking
available for research purposes
uh the answer to that is that the
plugins are designed explicitly for that
we definitely encourage you
to use it for all kinds of applications
and we look forward to what you use it
for
let's see next question
how do the cpu and ram usage after i can
scale
with scene size and another question
related question was how does it scale
across
platforms so answering the platform
question first because it's pre-computed
the cpu
cost tends to be on the low side because
we're not doing that much
compute on the fly so um
we've actually uh in terms of platforms
we've actually had it run
on an android phone although you will
have to test to see how many how much
source count you can support
in on the xbox certainly you can throw
many tens of sources
at it or with a prioritization scheme
even hundreds of sources at it and it
works
but i would say on a mobile phone for
example
or a lightweight vr platform definitely
a few sources but the exact numbers are
uh difficult but it's it does work in
real time
on an android phone we've tested that
much and as you saw
on the hololens also it works which is a
similar mobile processor
and as to how it scales with scene size
the baking will cost more
but the cpu and ram usage can be held
pretty still because
we have streaming support so you don't
load up the whole data set into memory
but you can tile it up and load it
piecemeal and that's already supported
in our unreal and unity plugins
and the cpu cost itself is quite
insensitive to scene size
all right and we have some more
questions coming in
let's see so there was a question
about connections to graphics research
uh like spherical projections and uh
transfer functions and if
this technology could be uh used for
electromagnetic waves or global
illumination
there's definitely connections there
because the core technology here is a
wave solver
although the perceptual compression
portion is not as relevant there
but yes some of these ideas of
like pre-computing and compressing have
applications there
in fact there are very close parallels
to precomputed lighting and my
long-time collaborator on this project
john snyder he
made some original contributions in that
area so
we're well aware of the connections here
and yes
this is an interesting area for sure
um let's see just looking for some more
questions here
right so one question is what is the
increase
in uh memory usage for the doors feature
i showed at the end
and it doesn't cost any extra memory it
like the it's the extra memory is very
minimal
you just need to have one more listener
location at each door which is
you probably already have anyhow the
cost is more on the cpu side
and this this is a new feature that some
of our partners
are trying out and so far we haven't
heard complaints about a cpu cost either
because it's it's not for example it is
not doing a global search in the scene
to figure out which doors are on the
path it's leveraging
the data that's already pre-computed
specifically the delay data
so it's we hope it's a pretty
lightweight extension frankly
okay a question after that it's a very
boring question what are the costs of
azure cloud compute
uh just rough numbers so you could
um it's it costs two cents
roughly speaking just ballpark it costs
two cents
with on azure low priority to do one of
the big simulations i showed you
and in a typical scene you will have a
thousand ish probes like a gears of war
scene is
on the scale of say one to two thousand
probes
so you can do the math from their few
tens of dollars to make
a decent like big sized game scene
all right
so just going through more questions
here
so one question is are you using a
hybrid method for numerical acoustics
for lower mid frequencies and geometric
acoustics for high frequencies
currently we're not currently we're
finding that if you can simulate up to
say one kilohertz
then most of the building scale
diffraction effects that
uh that are important in virtual reality
and games like obstruction effects you
can get a
you can get a good handle on them but
certainly
uh it's a very interesting direction to
look into
uh all right so
i think um
yeah just sorting through the questions
here
what is the typical resolution for the
spatial simulation grid
created by games
it's a presumably it's a compromise for
memory usage
yes it is and so how many listener
positions typically
so i i think i already answered that
it's a few thousand positions
and the resolution is on the scale of
meters
um
so that's the resolution on the listener
side it's it's in a few meters range
so of course if your scene is smaller
you can sample more densely
but uh for if you have high resolution
needs over a vast scene then you
probably want to section it up into
various data sets
which is feasible to do oh
here's a fun question how to use it for
underwater sounds
i think you can't but i'd love somebody
for
to try it it would be interesting um
for sure like what people do in ocean
acoustics it's
it won't work for those sort of
engineering scenarios because the
physics is very different
you have layer density so speed of sound
changes with depth and there's lots of
lots more effects to worry about so the
basic physics we're assuming here is
quite different
but if if what you mean here is uh for
artistic effect for underwater sounds
then
then perhaps something could be done to
take the parameters and tweak them in a
certain way
to to give the sort of underwater
artistic underwater effect that games go
for
and okay this is a good question that i
that highlights the limitations so
wave methods are pretty computationally
intensive so how are you doing it for
the full bandwidth
and the answer there is we're not as i
mentioned earlier so what we do is we
just assume the parameters we
computed for say up to 500 hertz or one
kilohertz we just apply them for the
full bandwidth
which is not the right answer and it
also goes to uh
to the point about a b comparison and
accuracy
is this is good for um
as a starting point but we definitely
want to
make the solver faster and our intuition
up to now is if we can pull off
one to two kilohertz then for most
scenarios that we've seen till now
things work out quite well
okay so and this is going to be my last
question and if i didn't
get to um your question please feel free
to email me i
i'm loving the questions i got here and
i'm very happy to answer them
later as well so this question is can
you scale the walk silver's resolution
and does it change the cloud processing
time or
real-time performance and quality so we
do cover it in the docs and you can
reduce the simulation frequency and
we've actually for
preview grade oralizations even 250
hertz
does something reasonable and it
computes much faster as well
the loss there is that your voxels are
so so big
that windows and doors can be just
filled in by the voxels
so that's the loss in quality in terms
of real-time performance is the same
really so changing the resolution
changes
only the bake time how much cost you
pay during baking
all right so to wrap up here
thank you so much for your interest in
my talk today
and definitely look at the resource list
to your right i've
um there's a link to the deck itself the
triton research page and also a link to
project acoustics
toolset and also to the project
acoustics forums so that's also a great
place to ask us questions if you're
thinking about
a fit and the fit for this for a
particular research project or a product
that you're thinking of
and then there's a few publications and
related podcasts the last link is
something that went live very recently
it talks about the audio research in
general at msr so it also talks about
the hrtf research that i touched on
briefly
that's happened in microsoft research
and yeah i'm i'm i really just look
forward to
what you all do with this this tool set
we're really hoping that
that was that's the intent behind making
it so widely available
is people experiment with it you try it
out for your projects
you see what works what doesn't you
can you're welcome always to come on to
the forums
and tell us what you found missing so we
can keep improving it and also
that informs our research on this going
forward
and that's it and i'll reiterate that
please feel free to email me if you have
questions you need answers too
so thank you so much for attending and
your interest and have a great day
you